hello and welcome
to this video okay
there's a small gap i did not upload the
game before that was a
somewhat weird game i lost that game it
was that was not the point it was a
provisional account that i
accidentally accepted and
those games always i know
and i
there are just many cheaters on those
accounts like
very frequently this game i don't think
that was a cheat um
actually but it was just so
uncomfortable
the whole time so i felt
um that was just absolutely not
enjoyable at all
so i i ditched that recording
um what's going on here i'm
kind of inventing stuff here in that
line in the
in the hedgehog don't know this
yeah i mean he won't run the rook i
guess
but centralizing the queen could be good
anyway
i have to be wow d5 d5
was something here
and now d5 i can take with the knight
okay
now it's a thread again
yeah maybe i just should go back there's
also knight x6 i just spotted this
idea
but it should never lead to anything
right
no yeah come on okay i don't want to
be in that tactic the whole time
would be really annoying yeah i'm not a
fan of the position here
i somehow played d4
while i was telling the story about the
game before
and that is not actually a line that i
[Music]
play
so i'm playing something that i don't
really know
i usually play with b3 there not quite
sure what i was thinking
here black is certainly uh okay
something like d5 now is okay but
not the only way to to do it
it's got some oops some pressure here on
that pawn
that's a good move
[Music]
[Music]
um
yeah maybe some counter play with knight
h5 queen g4
okay i can take on g7 here right
didn't even think about it i mean maybe
everything else was lost
as well but okay king h6 is the only
move that wasn't totally clear to me i
mean i
i always have a draw so this is um
this is the thing but i should win
somehow right
king h6 queen f6 check king takes h5
where is the mate h3g4 is the mate
a3 g4
check check check
queen g4 check king h6 queen g7
takes it
[Music]
where's the mate i'm just a tactical
idiot
queen g4 king h6
this
i don't see the mate this is really
really bad
h3 for g4
i'm fairly certain that this is winning
quite quickly
but i thought i should have a checkmate
and i didn't see it
and now king g2 here for f3 check rook
h1 mate i don't think he can stop that
i mean i saw that relatively quickly i
just thought there must be some check
check checkmate sequence and there was
none i didn't see any
this is the second mating idea
f3 actually would have this check so
rook h1 seems good
yeah let's mate next right f3 mate or
krook h4 made
yeah that was a strange game i think um
i was really not in good shape like here
the position is just
very comfortable for black i want to
check this d5
tactic did i miss that early on okay i
played
this and now i played queen e4 i had d5
did i miss that
d5
i can take with a knight yeah okay that
wins
win stuff okay
so this and then knight f4 knight f4 now
d5 i can
take with any of the two knights but
there's really nothing
there's nothing special
um quite the opposite i think black is
fine if he goes b5 now or
the way he played also seemed perfectly
reasonable
like this is completely okay and now
bishop a3
is not really good i mean not really
good is
wrong i mean it's awful because i can
take on g7
yeah yeah that's a bad prophylactic
mindset in a way because
the thing is from a structural point of
view black is doing really well
like if you think about an end game
they would just pile up on the a file on
that pawn
and have the better prospects the only
real idea that i have is that counter
play on the
on the king based on those three pieces
so he should rather
think about a prophylactic move and stop
potential attacks and um bishop a3 is
completely the opposite removes a key
defender
yeah i was still surprised that he took
so quickly
on on g7 i mean it's
in a way the only practical move i'm
sure but still
so it's made in 10.
let's see if i found the quickest one or
this this so g4 is
quicker and then king h1 as i see but
this is also
it seems a force made so i didn't do it
so terribly
yeah it was it was okay it was not
what's not terrible
i just thought like when when we were
here
there could be some made in three or so
that i'm missing i didn't see it
i just didn't see it um this is
also looking quite good right
so check and then
h3 for this mate okay this is also quite
quite nice or
check on h7 sometimes right
like if if he does that i this is also
made
silly this is not covered actually
so there's only bishop c1 i see that
bishop c1
which which i just take right and then
this is the quickest mate
also quite fun yeah so this is the thing
yeah here black should be aware
that he's much better from a strategic
point of view and just has to stop
my counter attacks yeah and and tries
him
and a move like
rook d8 i mean the engine finds a couple
of draws which
is kind of believable if you
this kind of thing i would have happily
played
yeah here white would even win but
king h8 and now just um yeah irritate
a blacky on that side of the board okay
guys thanks for watching